on planet Earth life has tried for
millions of years creatures big and
small have found ways to adapt and
evolve to flourish in all types of
environments but recently things have
changed new life forms have started to
appear strange fleshless creatures made
up your meat they have taken many forms
some delicious some dangerous but one
thing is clear about this new addition
to the Natural order
we humans are about to be put into the
grinder
oh internet welcome to film Theory the
show that just found itself a new pet oh
poor baby you and I have very different
reactions I feel like this is a
squishmallow waiting to happen oh just
look at this guy he's adorable I just
want to give his little fleshy head of
Pat and wait what's that little guy what
you want everyone to subscribe oh come
on now guys I say no to this little fish
by the way do you guys do you guys like
protein a nice steak that would look
great on a plate in a pie sewn into a
dress well do I have a surprise for you
friends it is meat weekend loyal
theorists that's right it's our very
first four-way crossover for the theory
channels and Phil thought what is
something that truly unites the worlds
of gaming film food and style and then
it hit us in the face like a wet sloppy
slab of beef meat and thus mystery meat
weekend was born baby yep over on Game
Theory you can see us cover the latest
round of merge Mansion lore for Grandma
Ursula's fill in her pies with some
unconventional choices of meat just hope
that Pedro Pascal makes it out alive
meanwhile over on food Theory we're
looking into the very real science
behind Mammoth meatballs yep you heard
that one right scientists have cloned
the meat of extinct woolly mammoths the
first thing that we humans did we
decided to cook it up and put it in her
mouth sounds pretty darn accurate
speaking of putting things in our mouth
holes over on style Theory we're
covering whether or not you could eat
Lady Gaga's Infamous meat dress because
if you are what you eat then why not eat
what you wear yeah making a dress out of
meats that was pretty darn weird but not
nearly as weird as what we're about to
cover here today on film Theory you see
today we're talking about the strange
thick meaty world of Vita carnus the
next species on our list is the meat
snake Okay okay when you're
underconfident about your meat snake
it's just really cold outside okay yes
we here at Team theorists are indeed a
bunch of mature adults a ton of people
were recommending that we check this
series out over on our subreddit and in
the comments on GT live so if you ever
have yourself a suggestion for Content
like this that you want us to look at
those are two great places to go make
those recommendations and I am really
glad that you guys put this one on our
radar this is an analog horror series
that you can go watch right now for free
on youtube.com created by artist and
filmmaker Darian quilloy but unlike
pretty much all other analog horror
series Vita Carnes isn't leaning into
uncanny liminal strangeness like the
back rooms or weird twisted
doppelgangers like Mandela catalog or
even nostalgic mascot horror like uh
pretty much everything else instead the
creep Factor here is coming from
horrifying creature design Vida Karnes
is the story of weird meat-based
creatures that have started appearing in
nature let me just say this one up front
this is one of the most original analog
horror series that I've seen in a long
time the monsters are made of Flesh and
eat bones they also grow like plants
it's a very cool idea in the series we
learn most of our information through
documentary tapes filled with strange
glitches but there's also archived home
videos and newspaper clippings thrown in
for good measure and where there's
Creepy Hidden details you know that
there's plenty of lore to decode in
short I devoured my time with Vita
carnus and let me tell you the deeper
and deeper we get into this documentary
the more pieces of the puzzle that start
falling into place where is this mystery
meat coming from why is the government
trying to cover it all up and is there
anything that we can do to stop what
seems to be our inevitable trip to the
meat grinder season your food and ready
your meat snakes friends today we've got
ourselves a lot to chew on so to start
things off what exactly is going on as I
mentioned at the top of the theory the
bulk of Vita carnus story is told
through a documentary put together by
the national living meat research to
educate the public and by extension us
about the creatures in this new genus of
skinless animals made out of muscle
organs and Bones they're called Vita
carnus Latin for living meat are we all
just alive meat right I feel like this
is just stating a statement of facts
like oh yeah you're living me and not
only do they look like raw meat they
also love to consume raw meat obviously
not a concern for all less fleshy meat
sacks out there as The Story Goes these
creatures basically appeared out of
nowhere starting in 1931 and their
population quickly skyrocketed over the
subsequent decades the documentary is
quick to point out that the origins of
these creatures are solely to Earth
miraculously out of nowhere seemingly
ruling out that they're aliens or demons
or any other classic analog horror fair
in fact their taxonomy is really well
laid out across these videos the Vita
carnus genus is split into several
species some cute some useful and some
literal nightmare fuel that'll get you
second guessing your next hike out into
nature in fact the more we hear about
each of these types of Critters the more
the Dark Truth of this world starts
coming into Focus the first few
creatures are weird but more or less
benign the most abundant of these is
known as the crawl which are these sort
of vines that resemble intestines
growing across the entire world this
stuff is edible and apparently makes for
a good meat substitute to the point that
it's been domesticated and used in
several popular in-universe meals in
fact one of the videos on the channel is
a tutorial on how to create a Cheesy
pasta dish using the crawl today's dish
will be a Cheesy egg watch out boys
looks like we have ourselves another new
entrant in The babish Culinary Universe
the second type of creature is known as
trimmings these things grow from the
crawl fall off and then start skittering
around on their own they're basically
sad little flesh turtles that run hide
and scream
next up is my personal favorite of the
bunch the meat snake look at this
one-eyed monster
yeah what can I say I just love myself
some meat snake according to the lore
these things are basically dead body
garbage disposals crawling around and
eating dead carcasses animal or
otherwise and then what might be one of
the coolest bits a creature design that
I've seen from an analog horror series
in a while they take the skulls of the
creatures they consume and then use them
as their own normally these things are
only supposed to grow up to 5 meters or
16 feet which is already pretty darn
long but astute viewers can actually
find a hidden newspaper clipping that
confirms that they can grow to be much
larger after World War II a quote
extremely engorged meat snake of
impeccable size their words not mine was
discovered in a tunnel underneath
Germany which consumed so many dead
bodies from the war that it grew to
eight times the average length the skin
of this Behemoth was also more powerful
it was darker and harder than a normal
meat snake I don't know how much of this
is actual lore and how much of this is
just trolling anyway the scientists who
found it had a lot of difficulty cutting
through the meat snake and with that
it's here that the creatures of Vita
Cardis take a hard right turn away from
weirdly cute with funny names into pure
distilled nightmare fuel next up we got
ourselves the mimic which are exactly
what they sound like humanoid creatures
with creepy Smiles bulging eyes extended
Limbs and a Diet composed of human flesh
[Applause]
oh geez I did not expect that at all
these puppies are fast too The More
Humans they eat the more human they look
and the darker their skin becomes that
last part sounds like a weird detail but
now that's the second time that we've
heard it mentioned so feels like an
important detail to keep in the back of
our minds mimics will pick out a Target
use clothing to disguise themselves or
even go so far as to hide in the
furniture in an attempt to capture their
prey don't know how a tall lanky flesh
monster is gonna be hiding in the family
beanbag chair but sure we'll just go for
it and yet despite the massive threat
that this thing poses to humankind
doesn't really seem that there's all
that much being done about it sure
apparently the world governments have
offered advice to their citizens but it
all really amounts to don't die LOL
because of the obvious threat this poses
on Humanity Nations around the world
have released instructions on how to be
able to fend for yourself in a mimic
encounter here are the instructions
the horror only continues with the next
creature too called the Harvester these
are large masses of Flesh that plant
themselves in the earth and then extend
Roots out in all directions but unlike
typical crawl these roots have literal
thorns in them that'll stab into any
large animal that walks on them the
worst part of all this the Thorns are
full of Venom that disable the nervous
system and prevent a victim's blood from
clotting which means that they're gonna
kill him from blood loss so the body can
then be consumed and if all of that
wasn't bad enough there's apparently no
way of surviving this if you are stunned
by a harvester there will be no way of
helping you being that there is no cure
and fatality is 100 positive we later
see and hear what a death by Harvester
is like in the video species anomaly
report and let me tell you it is not
Pleasant now normally at this point a
script I'd insert a little clip here to
help illustrate my point but let me tell
you it's rough even for me just take my
word for it it is scary stuff as if we
needed more reasons to not go and touch
grass and then we have what might be the
creepiest of these freak shows the host
of in influence creatures with
semi-humanoid torsos and masses of vines
that burrow into the ground spines
extend from their backs releasing clouds
of orange spores that can infect other
organisms from there the spores go
directly into the brain and temporarily
alter the minds of the victims
compelling them to sacrifice themselves
to the host which yes I too have seen
the last of us thank you very much
someone called Pedro Pascal looks like
we're gonna need his help again meet
weekend more like Pedro Pascal weekend I
wonder if I could figure out a way to
work him into the meat dress episode if
I did go down to the comments and say
like hey I understood that reference
just to show everyone that you were here
that you have officially completed the
meat cycle anyway in the most recent
video on the channel message we see a
newspaper clipping that says that the
authorities are refusing to handle any
Harvesters why are they scared is there
nothing they can do no I don't think so
remember oh I just talked about the
hosts releasing clouds of orange powder
well later on in the channel there's
that random cooking upload that I made a
joke about earlier the cheesy crawl
casserole well in that video we watch as
they use a special seasoning called the
nutrier co flavor enhancer a
suspiciously orange powder not only that
but the company's logo is a black circle
with a red triangle in the middle this
exact series of shapes flashes across
the screen during a similar part of the
documentary talking about the hosts
these hairs are barrels that release
spores produced within house spotty by
being fired into the air these spores
are hazardous so keep clear of them at
all costs see it right there for that
single frame it's the exact same logo
clearly these two things are connected
and just like with the spores the flavor
enhancer is apparently something that
people at nutria code don't want to be
inhaling for themselves for a moment
during our cooking tutorial The Faceless
babish cook leans down and we get the
briefest glimpse of a gas mask covering
his face something else that lets you
know that something's just off about
this powder notice what else happens to
the soothing guitar background music
when the flavor enhancer gets added all
right finish preparing the dish with
your flavor enhancer but allow your dish
to cool to it the guitar gets crazy it's
almost like the mind of the player has
been altered in some way and did you
hear what she just said but allow to
cool to a temperature below 60 degrees
Celsius or else the enhancer will not
work the enhancer doesn't work if it's
above 60 degrees Celsius or 140 degrees
Fahrenheit conveniently enough that's
the exact temperature at which most
fungus dies like we talked about in Our
Last of Us video go figure and as if you
needed any more proof a newspaper
clipping from message reveals that
nutriko is facing charges from people
getting sick after consuming their
products so things are already looking
pretty darn bad for Humanity we've got
meat Vines everywhere humanoid mimics in
our furniture meat snakes and our
Subways poison in our powders and even
more reasons to fear going out on Hikes
but it's here that once again we reach a
significant change in tone veering from
analog horror spoofs to lovecraftian SCP
Terror with the monoliths these things
appeared in 1972 standing in a perfect
circle in a redacted location
surrounding something else that's been
redacted based on a map that we see in
the video we can figure out that the
location is on an island in Canada's
Hudson Bay and given that we see a map
in another video named message saying
that the Vita carnus creatures all seem
to be moving to this location this seems
to be the point of origin for everything
so what exactly are these monoliths well
there's seven entities that are roughly
the size of a 37 story skyscraper their
legs are firmly rooted into the ground
with dozens of long ropey tentacles that
move about creepiest of all though these
things just kind of stand around they
don't really react to anything at one
point several military vehicles
attempted to bomb the monoliths but they
just released an EMP pulse that disabled
the attack even the bombs that managed
to hit didn't do that much because the
monoliths just repaired themselves
however did you notice the important
detail here they released an
electromagnetic pulse to defend
themselves that right there that's weird
throughout the series we see a lot of
instances where the Vita carnus
creatures seem to be taking control of
or just outright destroying technology
during a glitch in the first documentary
tape we briefly see a newspaper clipping
reporting that a radio tower has become
overgrown by the crawl other newspaper
clippings report trimming infestations
under satellite dishes and still other
videos point out their interest in Tech
like television and radio trimmings also
enjoy things that you enjoy as well like
watching the television or listening to
the radio it would appear as though the
carnists are learning from this
technology since we're told that these
creatures are closely connected to
Nature it's likely that they're latching
onto these unnatural human Creations to
either spy on us destroy them or
ultimately use them against us now at
first glance at the Channel's uploads
that would seem like the end of the main
series releases sure there are some
found footage videos in the mix the
cooking tutorial a commercial for the
seasoning powder stuff like that but
outside of a re-uploaded compilation of
all the previous videos that seems to be
the end of the documentary segments that
form the foundation of this world except
that would be missing a huge final
reveal hiding in plain sight you see
what at first appears to be a rote
re-upload of all the shorter documentary
segments put together actually contains
a final all-new monster a creature that
seems to be the one behind all of Vita
carnus's chaos this thing is known
simply as the singularity and it's
completely unlike everything we've
talked about so far it's a one meter in
diameter dark sphere that's floating off
the ground that's it it's a big old ball
we're told that several strange magnetic
fields and energy signatures are coming
out of the singularity but all the other
information about it is kept classified
and the government wants to keep it that
way you see according to a newspaper
clipping that we see on screen during
the latest video message the people at
National living meat research were
arrested for making this documentary
because it included quote sensitive
materials and defamation but why I mean
mimics and Harvesters are killing people
on mass hosts are spewing out
mind-altering spores and there's a
corporation selling those spores as a
spice to add to our food something feels
off here I mean what is the government
hiding well as the man uncovering the
conspiracy in the video puts it
versions and I suspect that the
singularity is at the center of it all
you see special reports and newspaper
clippings aren't the only thing that's
hidden under the surface of the series
disguised in the glitches of these
videos we can find pages from what
appear to be a children's storybook
telling the story of a long-lost prince
some parts of the pages are unreadable
due to either glitches covering up the
text video artifacting that blurs the
letters or just being cut off but we can
largely get the gist of the story so sit
down and relax as I tell you a Dark
Twisted tale Once Upon a Time the
magical royal family of a distant
Kingdom wished to discover new lands but
as they were traveling by sea their ship
was struck by a giant storm the prince
fell overboard eventually washing up
injured on an island he stumbles into a
nearby cave using what magic he can to
put himself into a healing sleep he
slumbered for a long time what seemed
like forever long enough for the land
around him to change and evolve into
something unrecognizable outside of the
cave a group of small Critters began
living on the island struggling in times
of hardship when there was too little
food to go around eventually the
critters found The Sleeping Prince Oscar
struck by his magic some of them
wondered if they'd be able to use the
prince's magic to grow food and heal
sickness but the majority agreed that he
was too dangerous and should be left
alone despite this some Critters ignored
the decision sneaking what food they had
to feed the prince hastening his
recovery thanks to them the prince awoke
and now fully recovered the prince
befriended the critters they formed a
bond with the critters leading the
prince to their home inside the forest
they asked the prince if he would be
able to help them since the forest was
unable to provide everything they needed
to survive the prince agreed using his
magic to summon mystical lights shapes
colors and figures the critters were
mesmerized by the prince's Brilliance
and they built the prince of raft so he
could return to his home Kingdom as he
left the prince vowed that with his
power in the aid of the Kingdom he would
someday return and heal the critters
home while on the surface this just
seems to be like an odd little Side
Story series of Easter eggs hidden in an
analog horror video to add to the
mystery it is far from that the way I
see it this is literally a metaphor for
the entire story that Vita Carnes is
trying to tell us the prince sets The
Singularity or whatever is at the center
of all this mess and Canada controlling
the rest of these meat creatures around
the world I suspect it's from some super
powerful alien civilization while
traveling the cosmos with others of its
kind just like the prince on his ship
it's hit by some sort of tragedy in
space either a supernova or some sort of
big bang something that is so powerful
that our pathetic little human meat
brains can't comprehend the scale either
way this alien creature is separated
from all the others and then it crash
lands here on Earth millions of years
ago in what eventually becomes modern
day Hudson Bay it's there in the Hudson
Bay that this alien entity forms an
island that exists in the world of
viticarnis but not in our own world
injured by the impact whatever this
creature is went into hibernation that
has lasted itself hundreds of millions
maybe even billions of years at least
long enough that it seems that the
origins of these creatures are solely to
Earth miraculously out of nowhere
tectonic activity and life on Earth
reshaped the planet above it just like
the world outside the princess cave
changed while he was asleep eventually
intelligent life formed on the planet uh
slowly humans we're the critters from
that story using up the resources of the
world and struggling to survive at least
in the eyes of this more highly evolved
being Some Humans eventually find the
entity in the 1930s and while most of
the people in charge wanted to leave the
creature be others didn't they saw it as
a way to progress to save themselves and
the species from dwindling resources on
Earth as Humanity Rings it dry and why
wouldn't they it's this incredible
lovecraftian being beyond anything we
understand and the organic material it
creates helps the natural life cycle of
Earth but due to its unique life cycle
where old branches fall off and Decay
into nutrient Rich compost all forms of
life seemingly flourish instead a cult
forms in the highest rankings of
humanity in governments and corporations
and militaries all of them focused on
somehow resuscitating this mysterious
being see this symbol on the flag that
was put on the prince's raft that they
rebuilt it's the same symbol that we see
on the flavor enhancer it's the same
thing that gets called out in multiple
other videos it's the symbol that
represents whatever this cult worshiping
The Entity is and how do they plan on
bringing it back well just like the
prince in the story they start feeding
the entity they start feeding it meat
specifically humans that's why nothing's
being done about the mimic or Harvester
attacks that's why the Mind Control
spores are being distributed as
condiments that's why people are
encouraged to eat the crawl and pretend
that everything is okay and normal
that's why the Elder mimics and the
giant meat snake that they found in the
tunnel are so much more powerful than
the others they've eaten more humans
they've grown stronger and darker as a
result not quite as dark as the prince
or the singularity a Giant floating
black ball but both the mimic
documentary and the meat snake archival
video make a specific point to call out
the color it grows a thick dark coating
of a flexible skin a typical meat
snake's color is bright Reds and light
Browns this particular meat snake was a
very deep maroon and I gotta say at this
point it seems like the cult's been
successful give the explosive growth of
the Vita carnus over the past Century so
is that it for Humanity is the world
doomed to fall to this lovecraftian
alien being in the cult following it as
it slowly awakens from its Slumber
thankfully not yet the latest video
gives us hope since it appears that the
people behind the Vita carnus
documentary are connected to another
organization that's starting a
resistance known as the containment and
research consult Association Society or
carcass for short it's an acronym we
love ourselves a good acronym they've
started their own recruitment drive and
are attempting to blow this conspiracy
wide open and that's about it actually
that's about as far as the story's
gotten at this point let me tell you I
for one cannot wait to see where this
one goes next like I said at the top of
the episode this has been one of the
most original analog horror series I've
watched in a while and I hope that us
covering it here gets more eyeballs over
to darion's hard work and spine chilling
Arts but while this may be all that we
have right now for viticarnis it is not
all that we have for mystery Mead
weekend my friends remember to go check
out all the other videos at our sister
location since we've been talking about
eating Vita carnis in this episode might
I recommend checking out what we have
cooking over on food Theory you ever
wonder what a mammoth meatball tastes
like well I'm about to tell you it is
literally like we're living in Jurassic
Park let's just clone an extinct
creature but instead of creating an
amusement park let's just create an
equivalent of a restaurant good job
humans that video is on screen right now
so click it and enjoy all the Savory
goodness that is is meat week as always
my friends if you're hungry for more
juicy content click that subscribe
button across all our channels and
remember it's all just a theory a film
Theory and cuts
thank you